في الحقيقه راينا تنديد همم من الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان بجريمه تزويج هذه الفتاه
الخاصه كيف يمكن ان تقييم موقف الرئيس هل
بمناسبه الانتخابات ما الذي يمكن ان توقعه
منه في مثل هكذا
حالاتكم
جاءت من رئيس اردوغان وبعدها
فان الاعلام
الدعم للحكومه
هذه الحلاوه
لخصوها في مجرده عناوين صحفيه هذه من
اردوغان لانه اشعار بالاحراجه ايضا
ومروعه
عمل حقيقي
بالتحديد لا تتوقع من اردوغان ان يتصرف في
وجه مثل هذه القضايا ولا على الاقل لحد
الانتخابات القادمه لانه بحاجه ماسه الى
الدعم السياسيه
بالحديث عن الانتخابات القادمه هل يمكن ان
نشهد فيها اي نوع من التغيير هل يمكن ان
يكون فيها اي مفاجاه ما الذي يتوقعوا من
هذه الانتخابات
اه اي ثنك
سباق المحتدمن فالاحزاب السياسيه الشكلت
تحالفا
ويبدو ان هم متقدمون على اردوغان
واعتقد بان هذه اصعب انتخابات سيواجهها
اردوغان الى الان
السلطه في عام 2002
ويحصل تغيير في الحكومه ولكن بالتاكيد
ستكون معركه محتدمه لان اردوغان لا زال و
سياسي كاريزماتي وهو في السلطه موضوع 20
عاما
وتركيا
مع بدون اي فرصه للانتخابات
فاعتقد بان سباق